hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
well not really but drunk minecraft
with bob and wade hey you guys how's it
going hey guys
november are you participating i was i
was until i decided to cop out because
my beard is not exactly any sort of good
mark gross beard that looks kind of like
a sasquatch's beard
my beard my beard my hair is kind of
like beard the hairs go out of my face
and then
back into my face and then it loops in
and out like that it's very strange
don't don't don't look at me when i'm
not shaving okay so as you can see we're
all stone cold sober
and we need to fix that so everybody
what are you drinking today
bob you you google uh i'm drinking
exactly the same thing
in a much smaller glass this time yeah
so we'll see if that helps with the
falling out of my chair issues i don't
think that was a problem for everyone
watching well i have this wrap around
desk
so i can't actually fall out of my chair
but i can
i would have been like rolling around on
the floor oh yeah i gotcha
that's that's a good thing okay wait
what are you drinking
i'm drinking reds apple ale red's apple
ale not sponsored by reds apple ale
also he's not a girl it's just a girl
hey i i wouldn't be offended by that
wade that is a perfectly acceptable
drink i love
it's all i had in the fridge honestly
this
it is tasty but it is going to be not
sponsored by heartbeats yeah not
sponsored by anything by the way this
show is not sponsored in any way at all
so
i'm drinking uh the same old that i well
not really i'm drinking um
diesel roano and monster because i
didn't have any other mixer
monster shut up it's all i have so much
monster
i bought like a 24 pack from sam's club
not sponsored by sam's club we're saying
a lot of brand names in like the first
two minutes
not sponsored by any of these but
we can't be sponsored can we does that
work can you have sponsors on youtube i
don't know
you know i know that the comments are
all [ __ ] up now so i don't know
what else is changing i mean we could
spend a whole episode talking about how
effed up the comments are
we will we will we'll talk about that
but in the meantime it's time to start
the drinks guys
you guys ready i'm ready are we like a
drink or something yes
this is the first drink of the night
whoever uh finishes
last is gonna be the hunter in this game
which we're gonna talk about
you ready ready all right last yeah go
three
two one go
i'm done it's a small class but i'm done
holy hell man
i need to drink more this is delicious
this is delicious by the way belched all
over my webcam
and you guys probably not believe me
that i'm done but i show the webcam
i believe you you know bob i've learned
to believe you when you finish your
drink because
i i've been there i know i know
firsthand
when i finish a drink i finish a drink
all right so anyway i when your mom
finishes a drink she sits around the
house
do you guys ever feel like ozzy osbourne
if he was a female
no what what what does that even mean
no wait wait explain yourself on that we
were supposed to drink not smoke a bunch
of crack
wade's gotten into some bad habits in
the down time of drunk minecraft
you guys don't know me you don't know
what it's next time on
addict minecraft this might be mark
spends five hours sitting in the corner
rocking back and forth
sells three stacks of dirt for six
dollars he can score some smack
about 20 dirts in my pocket ten years
when we uh
try to up ourselves from drunk minecraft
each time it's just going to turn into
just
heroin so i found this room
yeah look at this segue i found this
room
what's in here oh okay what's in here oh
yeah we're playing
whack-a-mole uh no no no no no wait oh
god damn it wade you [ __ ] [ __ ]
well i guess we're in the game now well
i guess wade is a hunter even though
bob won
no it was supposed to be now you you you
know that bob won that come on wade i
didn't finish that
no but i mean he's it's a technicality
he won you know you need to change the
rules
this is my series i can do whatever the
damn hell
[ __ ] i want is this why the mom and i
participated anything
the way you've wanted it to be you're
right it is i like it
i like the ready up switch whoa what'd
you do hang on
i'm gonna drink i'm gonna drink more you
guys i don't have any i'm not
i can't do anything i guess we're kind
of trapped here
what in the hell
i don't know what's supposed to be
happening now
the molds are ready ah
i put like half a bottle of desorato in
here
it's you know it's sweet but it's i
don't have permission
wait remember use teamwork and then oh
god oh oh
i didn't read it well i didn't have
permission
mark i i read it this is already failing
what what was that
it said use teamwork there's a pressure
plate on the giant tree
oh okay start over you drive no we're
not gonna start over you let us do what
we do hi wade
how's it going
you know what wade you can be the hunter
that's okay let me try to um
in the in the six minutes that we've
started i have not explained this yet
all right the rules the rules i'll read
the rules yes you guys can't do it yeah
go ahead the rules
play peaceful hunter cannot go in the
holes
and always listen to your teammate to
help them that's a weird rule yeah
no going into creative mode don't be a
dick
implied hint there's a pressure plate on
top of the tree that will blow it up
oh okay i'm actually glad that um bob
isn't the hunter because then i would be
on a team with wade and
us cooperating would not go over well oh
you're the hunter
no wait go go stand on the thing let's
do this wait go bob be the hunter
get on the thing wait get on that thing
i'll pick you up what's the pickup
there we go all right ready bob
yep ready buddy use teamwork mark and
there's a pressure plate on the giant
tree they've really been reiterating
that point that there's a pressure plate
on the giant tree i really wonder if
it's all that
armor oh all right get get get a set of
stuff
he's got wood
no i all right let's go
hold it up mark let's clean it blow it
up
you want to ready up i did ready up you
ready up
the moles are ready the hunter is ready
all right all right so we're moles so we
got a chip
should we spread out mark food
the mole food i don't know what i'm
supposed to do here whoa food
oh no mark let me out
wade what are you doing just dance all
funny for the camera and it'll be
all fine mark should we split up and see
what's going on okay moles need to work
together to blow up the island
wade what did you do
can you see our nate oh that's not this
is not where i'm supposed to be
i i shouldn't be here huh
oh no oh god no my
my mole food and mold pants and mole hat
it's all gone right no mark mark mark
mark i shouldn't have taken all the mole
food
you suck wait i just found some at the
bottom of the thing
okay anyway so yeah uh
my mic yeah what day is it mike mike
hump day hump day
so which hole do you want to take mark
i'm gonna take the far hole try to
distract him
wait don't listen wait don't listen
wait don't listen to me wait don't
listen
wait where are you i found a dark hole
it's terrifying wait wait i'm back here
oh no how do we get up
the tree i don't understand i don't know
i don't i got up
there there's a door on the uh on the
side of the tree
that you can um oh no oh oh oh
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
in the winner's circle oh wait how do i
wait
oh no oh no i can't how do i get higher
god damn it wade somehow i think
bob is supposed to or bob one of us is
supposed to be able to open the top door
while one of us enters like when one of
us enters the tree another needs to oh i
see there's a bed here
hey bob there's a mysterious bed here
so strange ah this sucks this sucks this
sucks this sucks
i followed you up the tree and got
trapped in the stupid thing in this
stupid
thing you guys wait a minute what are
these buttons in here dude there's one
blue one and one red one
in where in the room that you were
trapped in momentarily
don't come in here because it's gonna be
oh god
oh god what
we made it you having fun up there wade
i'm having a blast
okay how do we do this mark i don't
understand how we're supposed to be
pretty sure
we gotta somehow run distraction on
where his name tag
it's up above us he sees it holy crap do
you see those things
yeah what are those i don't know they're
like gearboxes i don't know what they
are
on my screen they they're like command
prompts yeah
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
distract him wait don't listen to me i'm
gonna distract him because he's such a
giant idiot that he
never will i do he would never know
what's going on and uh bob you're gonna
sneak
by him and you're gonna be able to go
around
i don't think
my distraction didn't work don't kill me
uh oh
no i go cause i'm closer yes
yes half of this battle is us getting
out of this damn room
that room sucks okay wade hey wait look
at my name tag
oh wait look at me wait wait you know
what you want me
wait there should be a way wait i'm
getting out wait i'm getting out wait
oh you can't get me wait uh i was
halfway up and he killed me and now i'm
in the stupid room
zombie why are we spawning in that room
wade what are you doing you can't do
that
it's illegal mark i'm stuck in here and
i cannot help you unless you get me out
all right here you go so if i could get
the rest of my armor i currently only
have a leather shirt and wade can one
shot me
ah way down my axe's name is betty
is it it literally is wait so can i like
team chat can i send mark private
messages
oh he's gonna get me
wait you can't come in oh that's smart
yes
okay we gotta i i don't know how to do
this wait i got an idea i know how to
communicate mark come here
okay what who's shooting arrows what's
happening
i think wade has arrows all right mark
yes
so this one yeah this one oh you can see
where we are
that one that we're talking about yeah
one of us
should do that one and then the other
yeah should uh go to that other one
uh over sneaking hide your name plate
oh
oh no you can't see us can you
so fools do you remember where that was
mark
yes i do are you over there i can be
you should go over there i'm going over
there currently
wait can you see us i'm not telling you
we do you you can't see us can you we're
saying let me know when you're ready
mark i am ready
all right let's do it let's do it
okay all right okay all right okay okay
hi wade
oh god it's not even fair
did you die mark yeah i got an item
called a blackjack what how did i just
get shot with an arrow wait you're such
a piece of crap wade why you gotta be
like wade
wait what are you doing you guys made me
this way i tried to like
i have a blackjack but it says i can't
use it
oh mark let me out let me out let me
know okay sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
there you go there you go there you go
okay get it out of here can you sneak
remember to be sneak snarky how do you
fall off of ledges if you're sneaking
jump jump okay
yeah just like uh i have no idea how
we're gonna do this mark i'm not even
i just don't know how to win i don't
either
hang on wait hang on
i got this i got this in the bag
i got this in the bag if we whisper
us
he's so quick he's too quick bobby's too
quick he can't do this
bob let me out i'm like i'm coming i'm
coming
i'm i'm coming zombie this is obviously
unfair
zombie we need something to make let's
play on our team zombie
this is this is not going well could i
be a mole instead of the hunter this is
too easy
i think we should make wade do a shot
everyone
if we were all three moles and zombie
was the hunter
yeah maybe ooh that's a cool thing
does that wear off uh i think it lasts
quite a bit
all right you want to try that thing we
did before yeah yeah
the second yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah got
it
you ready uh hang on hang on
uh uh uh
yes yeah okay just let me know when
you're gonna go
uh i'm ready for that to happen all
right you ready
ready uh yeah three
two one go go go go go go
he's watching you but i made it in i
made it in come to the tree
got you a bit oh what the hell that
blackjack didn't do nothing
wait mark mark what oh i wish there was
a way for me to communicate this to you
yeah
in a way that can i can i please send
you a message
i don't know bob i i really don't know
all right how about this mark you know
that command that we use a lot
while we die to go back to where we died
the slash back command
yeah that oh we just got book and quill
what is that here
oh yes that's beautiful so we're like 15
minutes in
oh he's got like 15 kills you shut up
wade as if it isn't easy for you
just another day opponent noobs guys
pruning scrubs me
bob i just got i just got an item did
you just get some items
uh yes you got the items
did you get that right here here here
okay uh ah
wait we're talking about you everybody
is so dear diary
wade is so ugly everybody looked at him
and died did you see my thing ah
you see that so that for me
that takes me back to where i want to be
right now oh
i like this this is a good idea
you don't even need to leave this room
from here oh you're right
we could so do you want to do the drink
this item now and then
yeah yeah oh my god your armor's not
invisible
don't say it i mean i'm a beautiful
cover girl
all right hang on right
all right
all right are you ready mark i'm just
i'm gonna go um
well whatever we'll see
are you here mark maybe
all right
bob are you here okay
there's a button
bob okay go for the button right outside
the tree
whenever you can okay okay why are you
guys so quiet
shut up wade shut up i just want to be
part of the group again
i don't think it's working
bob i don't i see you sneaking around
there wade
are you guys even in here
oh no oh no what happened
i died i died nothing you were doing was
working it was an opening
i don't know how that works i don't know
it doesn't i'm in that room and there's
a time limit on the stupid teleport now
oh frickity fresh for some reason
how'd you guys get invisibility shut up
wade we don't want to hear it
you failed even with great power no no
it wasn't working the door wasn't
opening bob was hitting the thing on the
outside it wasn't working
it was it seriously wasn't opening we
would have won there if it had freaking
opened it just didn't
zombae this is obviously unfair
teleporter
is that wade is the winner
uh wade is the doucher
zombie you're the best
oh god so where's that thing we gotta do
up here so where is that thing yeah
where's that uh thing i don't i don't
actually
see it do you know where it is mark i
don't i'm not up there
do we both have to be up here i don't
know or does just one of us have to get
up here and do it
i i don't know oh wait a minute i see it
uh oh uh
so with some zombie intervention
apparently nothing
i'm pushing the button there was
supposed to be an earth-shattering
kaboom
i don't understand what happened this is
a lie this this whole map is a ding-dong
damn
lie what oh god
that was better it was more like it
i don't know if we didn't understand
what we were supposed to do or if that
didn't work very well
i i sincerely think that we were doing
it like after we got the potions of
invisibility which was totally all these
games are kind of like hairy situations
holy crap i'm here i'm standing on one
block in the middle of no are you
i was kind of wigging out bye wade
i waited have fun down in deathland
okay oh goody goody gumdrops i think
that's
it but do you guys want to go again i'll
be the hunter yeah be the hunter zombie
can we get this reed
oh god lava lava lava la la la la la
are you making fun of me what are you
making fun of me man no i'm burning and
falling to my death oh my gosh
i don't know where all this lava came
from
actually oh god i've died
i don't know if zombie can get this
restarted
oh god we've been going for about 24
minutes so
oh it's up to you guys if we can get it
done quick i would want bob to be the
hunter because he was supposed to be in
the first place and
wait you said whoever finishes their
drink laughs yeah but that's obviously
not what i meant when i said it
oh i'm sorry that i actually listened to
your words you
should obviously you've been playing
with me long enough to know that that is
not how this works the one time the one
time i do what you say
and it's still wrong screwing you all
i'm going to be the hunter boop
all the dicks
here his dead body appeared on fire and
then it was gone
i'm haunting you you're haunting him but
why
why would you do that
all right no i'm not i'm the hunter no
i'm the hunter now
what the hell i'm the only mole is me
wade where the hell are you oh what the
crap get ready we'll
get ready bob for the last pounding of a
lifetime man
you guys suck so much zombie i expect
boons
many many boobs that's not even fair
wait
where are you i got teleported to bob
oh okay i guess you're a mole now so
you're gonna die like the rest of your
roles wait let me give you a message
before we start
all right i don't have a blog i got one
i got one
what's going on over there i hear click
clacking i hear the click click clickety
clack of a keyboard
guys got a weapon called excalibur last
time and didn't use it
what that doesn't sound fair
what are you talking about excalibur
nothing that's hardly fair
wait a minute why does wade get it above
all else
i don't have a weapon
oh boy oh i have a weapon come on let's
go bring it on
betty wants some blood
i'm just gonna sit here and drink until
you guys are here
did you read it wade uh read what
the thing i sent you of course did you
get that thing i sent you
of
wait are you just running distraction
what's happening
i'm just running wade doesn't know how
the moles work so he's just kind of
running to his death in the windmill of
axe blades
but bernie's sheriff if i just stand
here and
did you kill me yeah i think so
what is going on what is going on is
everybody
i don't know it's lava down here i can't
see you guys did you go stealth
did you go stealthy wealthy no
no i see someone lord minion
oh it disappeared it's so strange
leave it alone why did that happen i
can't do anything to you until you get
up here
i'm never coming up i just i like my
mole village god damn it i'm gonna come
down there if you don't come up here
no that's cheating wade you know that i
don't follow the rules you know this
explicitly from the first game we played
during this episode
oh i opened the tree that was me sorry
never mind
who's there who wants some who wants
some
bob distract him get into the tree don't
do it
where are you where are you guys i wish
you could see my screen i'm so trolling
you right now
dying i can't see anything
i saw that bob where'd you go you didn't
see
anything wait let's go open the door
you are very dead congratulations on
being dead and sucking
you get grade eight it's sucking ass
i don't understand how we're supposed to
do you bob
oh one knee do you see the smoke bomb i
just did did that do anything i didn't
see anything
huh one needs to be inside one needs to
be outside i don't even know what that
means
oh what is it the outside oh
the pressure plate on this oh the
pressure plate outside that's right
wait are you are you doing that i'm
working on it i see you
wade lord douchington
no you don't lord of the i see you yes i
do leave me alone
i see you i can't stop seeing you
i'm sorry you're just so pretty i can't
take my eyes off you oh
you're gone i guess you got ugly bob you
have to hit one of the pressure plates
wait bob did you do the wayback trick ah
bobby hi there
oh you're hitting me all right i got it
i got it go go go go i'm
dead you were just a little too slow
there
whoops
i see you there wade
wait what hey hey i heard a noise who's
in here
all right come on wade who is in there
done
oh no that really is scary because all
of a sudden you hit me with a blackjack
it makes a noise and it scares me
all right wait go go go go go go go go
go
go go go door is closed i don't know
what you guys are talking about
ow why are you doing this to me oh oh
you killed me
yes what can i
do i'm in the mall village oh open the
door
no opening no
i'm doing the thing bob stop doing the
thing get out of my way bob i gotta go
ow stop beating me with a blackjack it
really hurts
stop it i can't even click on you get
out of here get out of here
no no no that's right that's what i
thought that's what you get
i told you i really i really think this
door is kind of broken
i really i don't understand buttons were
supposed to be you guys actually do this
like
like one link here i'll come up wait
push push some pressure plates down
there i'm gonna stand on the top
pressure plate
it's not us drunks zombies said okay
wait go up there i'm
i wanted this place to blow up i'm up
here wait do do a downstairs one i am
i'm i'm stepping on the you have to have
one mole on each side of the door
what does that even mean
that doesn't make any sense
one person stands inside and outside
what
what what's that sound i don't know i'm
standing on the pressure plate out here
one more gets the jump boost one mole
stands outside to open the door okay
look
look zombie wade is standing right there
on the pressure plate to open the
door wait so look the doors all closed
oh was this a door closed oh yeah oh
there there goes the door
door opened how did the door open i
don't know don't ask me
i don't understand what's happening blow
it up
guys stay with me blow it up
there we go that's about damn time
this map sucked
it was awful i was the best hunter it
was
awful we're way out of time why are you
why are you being like this
why wait why why goodbye
we were brothers you son of a [ __ ]
i can't wait to see you all in hell
so one person gets inside the tree they
step on the pressure plate and they get
a jump boost that allows them to get to
the top of the map
but since they're inside the tree they
can't get to it they have to have a mole
that's on the outside
that opens the door for them and then
they can use that jump boost
you don't get the jump boost by standing
on it you give your partner the jump
boost
on the outside of the door what that
sucks
outside of the door at the bottom or at
the top at the top well how do you get
outside the door at the top in the first
place that was the problem
there's a bunch of trees you can climb
right up it's really easy wait you're
not
oh you never said that
i never said that wait wait bob he never
said that we get to the outside by
climbing other trees
you never said that
shotgun